les quatre cocktails molotov ont été
lancés contre semur provoquant aussitôt
un début d'incendié deux sur les quatre
n'ont pas explosé
ils étaient environ 2 heures du matin au
moment des faits et ce sont des
riverains qui ont donné l'alerté
dans un communiqué publié ce dimanche la
préfecture parle d'une attaque d'une
extrême gravité et dénonce ceux qui s'en
prennent lâchement un symbole de l'état
mais qui sont-ils justement et dans quel
but a été faite cette attaque tous les
moyens disponibles seront mobilisés pour
que les auteurs de ces actes en
répondent devant la justice répond le
préfet de région bernard schmeltz une
plainte a été déposée et une enquête
confiée à la police judiciaire
elle pourra s'appuyer sur les images de
vidéo protection et les analyses
techniques et scientifiques
la préfecture n'a pour l'instant pas
fait plus de commentaire